One of the least traveled countries is Mauritania.
This is not a place to visit if you are hung up on comfort and luxury,...
...but "roughing it" can have its own special charm, adding a sense of adventure.
Mauritania's best hidden secret is Ben Amera.
Mass tourism has not yet discovered this enormous rock,...
...which lies obscure in the middle of the desert.
Other monoliths like Aicha are close by.
You can kill two birds with one stone...
...by traveling to Ben Amera on the world's longest train.
The monolith is about 5 kilometers from the small village of Tmeimichatt...
...on the desert train route between Nouadhibou and Zouerate.
But don't expect any conveniences or amenities because the train is in a shabby condition.
However, if you are not fazed by delays and inconveniences,...
...and you enjoy an environment with some breathtaking desert sceneries,...
...this place will be for you.
You will never forget this experience!